we are going to begin with the news this
morning and it's coming out of
Washington a new report long awaited on
the FBI's investigation into Russian
interference in the 2016 election
special counsel John Durham says the FBI
made critical errors in handling that
investigation although Durham stopped
short of concluding that those mistakes
were politically motivated former
president Donald Trump was quick to
praise the findings which echoed or
largely echoed that is and inspector
General's report from 2019. CBS News
senior investigative correspondent
Catherine Herridge is at the Department
of Justice Force Catherine 300 plus page
report what's in it good morning
well good morning Tony the Durham report
found the FBI discounted or willfully
ignored information that did not support
the Russia collusion narrative House
Republicans now want special counsel
John Durham to testify about his
findings next week
after nearly four years of Investigation
special counsel John Durham found the
FBI lacked actual evidence to
investigate then candidate Donald
Trump's campaign in 2016. Durham said
the bureau was too reliant on
investigative leads provided or funded
by Trump's political opponents the
report did not reveal major new findings
but it repeated prior criticism from
Trump there was no collusion at all the
FBI expanded its original probe known as
Crossfire hurricane based partly on
information from Christopher Steele
Steele a former British spy put together
a research dossier alleging possible
misconduct between then candidate Trump
and Russia Durham found investigators
did not and could not corroborate any of
the substantive allegations contained in
the steel reporting this has been a big
black eye for a lot of the federal law
enforcement intelligence communities Bob
Anderson is a former senior FBI
executive where there's smoke there's
not always fire and I think taking that
extra second to look at this verify
things before you actually went down
that road might have been a little
better off the FBI investigation was the
basis for appointing special counsel
Robert Mueller who had an even broader
mandate there were multiple
systematic efforts to interfere in our
election Mueller's report concluded
there was insufficient evidence of a
criminal conspiracy involving president
Trump his associates and Russia every
time Russia is brought up they say oh
Trump what do I have to do with it in a
statement the FBI says it has
implemented dozens of corrective actions
which could have prevented errors made
by the bureau in 2016. on social media
former president Trump reacted to the
report saying the American people had
been scammed you don't ever want the
American people thinking that the United
States intelligence or the FBI is in any
way doing anything outside of just
looking at the facts
critics charge the Durham investigation
cost taxpayers more than six million
dollars and brought only two cases to
trial both men were found not guilty and
the third case ended in a plea agreement
Durham is recommending the creation of a
new position for politically sensitive
investigations in the future Gail
thank you Catherine some people think
that's a very good idea